hello everyone my name is Paul Miller
and I'm a physician who is the medical
director of the Colorado center for bone
research and I'm also my academic
appointment as distinguished clinical
professor of medicine at the University
of Colorado Health Sciences Center
that's my official title let me tell you
who I really am I'm a nephrologist by
formal training and I currently do a
fair amount of renal bone work in terms
of renal disease and the kidneys but
most of my work is a referral practice
in metabolic bone disease and clinical
trials in metabolic bone disease the
bone diseases that I manage are a lot of
complicated postmenopausal osteoporosis
and other forms of osteoporosis
including other secondary conditions
such as steroid osteoporosis post
transplant osteoporosis Mayo
osteoporosis and then a fair amount of
work and Paget's disease
osteogenesis imperfecta and I've had a
lot of experience in bone densitometry
development and application I've been
honored to be one of the founders of the
International Society for Clinical
densitometry the ised which is dedicated
to teaching physicians and technologists
how to do bone density correctly and
interpreting them correctly and good
good quality control I've also been
heavily involved in by chemical markers
of bone turnover development and and
they're particularly application and
clinical practice and that's the focus
this presentation today and I hope I can
make this both interesting for you and
exciting for you so that you begin to
learn how to apply bone turnover markers
for certain specific reasons that I
think are beginning to get more
utilization in the general
this community so let me go to my next
slide here and it almost looks like a
summary slide and it and it is in some
ways but it's not in other ways because
these are the points that I am going to
talk a little bit about throughout this
session and to provide some level of
evidence there's also a lot of clinical
personal experience on how I use markers
I use markers in untreated patients who
have high baseline values just for a
number of reasons high baseline values
predict a higher risk for fracture
beyond bone density alone and I'll
explain that why in a minute but I think
one of the things that I don't want to
forget is that high markers and we'll
talk about what markers are and what
markers are used but high markers also
think outside the box because not
everybody that's postmenopausal has high
markers has the high markers from being
estrogen deficient they could have high
markers due to another other conditions
that can cause high markers such as
myeloma or severe hyperparathyroidism or
another another other items secondly I
use markers in untreated patients that
tip the scale decide when to treat
because in the risk models that we have
the fracture risk models such as the
fracture risk assessment modeling
created by the genius of Professor John
canis and Sheffield and underwritten by
the World Health Organization the
validated 10-year data to use risk
factors to predict the 10-year risk of
all major fractures or hip fractures did
not include markers because markers
weren't available when fracks was
initiated it's not a flaw fracks is
simply a timing of the of how biology
and the information that's been has
changed over time people that have high
markers will approximately double their
fracture risk above and beyond what's
calculated by fracks alone and and I use
that value of a high marker in those
case
is where I'm trying to decide in
borderline cases of whether or not they
have a high risk in untreated patients
I'm sorry untreated patient number three
and particularly patients that are on
anti resorbed of agents such as
bisphosphonates or even fold those
estrogens or denosumab the markers in
the clinical trial data particularly the
CT to peptide the CTX is the bone
resorption marker that comes from
college in the collagen cross-linked
markers that are above 250 micrograms
per milliliter should raise some concern
about whether or not they're taking the
drug the compliance is bad whether
they're absorbing it it was an oral
bisphosphonate or there's something else
mitigating a bone biological effect now
as I'll go through the data here you'll
see that the normal premenopausal range
for the seat checks is approximately
from the best data we have about 150 to
650 Piko gram per milliliter and
certainly there'll be lots of people on
oral bisphosphonates that won't be below
250 that simply comes from some of the
Fosamax data that illiterate data the
Fosamax long term extension where the
majority of the patients were below 250
and sometimes a single value if it's
within a normal range but not be as good
as if it's a very high value or very low
value because you don't know where they
started from
but that's something to consider if it's
if it's above that level in treated
patients a change a drop from baseline
in a marker or an increase for the
antibiotic marker or marker there
stimulate bone information has has some
meaning the drop in a CT X from baseline
probably beyond 30% from the baseline
value or an increase in the anabolic
markers and this could be either
pro-peptide type one collagen or P one
and P or serum osteocalcin which fit on
the lines with very similar changes in
response to the only anabolic agent we
have currently available and that's
teriparatide
an increase to be 10 percent
above value above the baseline value
certainly is indicated they're having a
bone biological effect and then we'll
get into this very hot topic of the
issue of bisphosphonate drug holidays
and how markers might help us in
deciding whether the bisphosphonate is
still being recycled and be and working
or whether the bisphosphonate pool has
been depleted but let's start over with
going back to some basic biology and
that is what is turnover you and I men
and women alike we replace our entire
skeleton about every 10 years by process
called bone turnover or bone remodeling
they're fairly synonymous terms
throughout your entire skeleton you have
about 5 million of these each one is
called a B mu or bone remodeling unit
with any within any one unit there's a
fixed program and it takes about 120
days on average to complete this cycle
but it's the bone remodeling cycle where
bone resorption occurs and then bone
formation occurs and this has gone on at
different sequences throughout the
skeleton all the time and the purpose of
remodeling or turnover is twofold one is
to maintain the blood calcium be normal
because the the skeleton is the major
reservoir for calcium and you can't
maintain a blood calcium by taking in
calcium so there's this flux of calcium
in and out of the skeleton which is
regulated by a whole series of both
external and internal processes the
other purpose of remodeling is to repair
the little micro striated cracks the
stress damage that occurs when we're
doing activities like running or walking
or in Colorado skiing or whatever to
repair bone so this is the cycle within
any given level of a bone remodeling
unit that they're laying they're having
a holiday taking a rest and something
comes along and activates them
externally it's predominantly
parathyroid hormone
internally within the bone micro
environment one of the dominant
regulators is the rank ligand rank
system and that activation results in
bone resorption by the Ostia class it
takes about 30 days on average to carve
out an area of old bone and then right
behind that comes the activated
osteoblasts the cells on bone that make
bone to form bone put down bone matrix
and then bone calcium and replace that
amount of bone has been carved out when
bone is in good balance and so this
process of bone remodeling takes about a
hundred and twenty days on average to
complete from the cells and bone from
both the osteoblasts and from the bone
matrix the collagen are released
proteins into the blood that are termed
under generalized heading of bone
turnover markers that we can measure in
the blood and give us some sense not a
perfect sense but some sense of what's
happening with the remodeling rate with
the bone turnover rate end up in
patients now it's not clear what is the
optimal bone turnover rate we have some
data that if the bone turnover is too
high it can impair the strength of bone
and lead to fractures or the other
spectrum on the left hand side if the
bone turnover is too low so for example
in conditions where there's very high
bone turnover such as severe
hyperparathyroidism or space travel for
example or immobilization it can lead to
impairment and strength of bone quality
and bone strength on the other hand
there are conditions where we know that
that the bone turnover is too low and
those could be like renal a dynamic bone
disease
it might be the process one of the
processes that layer leads to impairment
bone strength and diabetes in people on
google corticoids but very low bone
turnover also is associated with poor
bone quality poor bone strength and and
increased fractures so how do we measure
these biochemically well here is a list
of the available bone turnover markers
are often abbreviated capital B TM on
the left hand side are the bone
resorption markers and on the right hand
side are bone formation markers on the
left hand side the the preferred and
these are preferred by both the
International osteoporosis foundation
and the International Federation for
Clinical Research who have met to come
to some consensus on this and the United
States by the American Association of
clinical chemistry and the National bone
Health Alliance a part of the National
Osteoporosis foundation who have come to
a agreement on preferred markers under
resorption markers the preferred marker
is the serum or in Europe it's the
plasma seat ela peptide receipt checks
this is a collagen cross-linked from
bone collagen it is specific for bone
collagen not from collagen of your knee
your nose there are other bone
resorption markers that are available
but not used commercially yet the trap
5b or tartrate resistant acid
phosphatase which is actually a cellular
marker of IC class and number rather
than true bone resorption on the right
hand side the bone formation markers and
the ones that are preferred are the pro
peptide type one collagen or P one and P
that comes from the osteoblasts but also
because as much more widely reimbursable
is the serum osteocalcin
particularly the mid hasta causa
molecule and I'll show you some data of
how the P 1 and P and the osteocalcin
track each other in almost a linear
fashion and their results the bone
specific alkaline phosphatase or BSA P
is also a very important marker because
it goes up in a lot of diseases that may
not be related to osteoporosis although
it can go up in osteoporosis as well
when you have high bone turnover but for
example on other bone disease such as
Paget's disease it's the preferred
marker it also goes up in the bone with
metastatic cancer it also goes up in
bone after a large bone fracture it also
goes up and boned with severe vitamin D
deficiency or osteomalacia and so it's a
very important marker to use for a
number of other different metabolic bone
diseases so this is a slide that I gave
this year at our annual ised meeting in
Orlando again the clinical use of
markers to explain in part the higher
fracture risks that may be seen at the
same bone mineral density to monitor
pharmacological response to treatment
that is valuable and complementary to
bone density because markers change
faster in response to treatments though
they'll change within a month or two
months or three months and provide you
an earlier feedback of what's happening
whereas bone density will take a year or
two to change to predict the rate of
bone loss there's data to suggest that
higher markers will predict higher rates
of bone loss we'll talk about holidays
and for you know for those of us that do
renal bone disease work and says I do
most of the bone biopsies for the Rocky
Mountain region and not everybody has
access to bone biopsies or bone biopsy
reading there's recent data indicating
and suggesting that specifically
measuring parathyroid hormone which we
won't talk about today or the bone
specific alkaline phosphatase may help
discriminate among some of the different
forms arena
bone disease or renal osteodystrophy and
in some cases may obviate the need for a
bone biopsy some potential advantages of
markers is because they represent an
integrated a dynamic assessment of
skeletal metabolism one of their
disadvantages and we'll show you the
next slide is that they can't tell you
what bone they're coming from or whether
they're coming from a single bone or
many bones we assume that in systemic
bone diseases like osteoporosis they're
an integrated measurement of what's
happening systemically the rapid and
large changes with therapy or all
therapy are probably one of their great
advantages and the assays are widely
available both commercially from
different labs and by different machines
and I think that some of the work that
we're doing right now is to try to
standardize some of these but they're
very accurate and widely available some
potential disadvantages these are slide
from my good friend and colleague UCSF
dr. Doug Bower again they could not
distinguish the where that's coming from
cortical versus trabecular bone there
are some markers that require that they
are collected fasting before 10 o'clock
in the morning and that's particularly
true of this of the bone resorption
marker the CT peptide there is between
laboratory variability standardization
needs to be improved harmonization of
the assay needs to be improved and the
project that we here are working under
under the leadership of the NBA is to
try to establish the consistent normal
reference database but with men and
women on both of the available
immunoassay machines the broach
diagnostic machine and the immuno
diagnostic machine it's important to
point out and to always bear in mind
that bone terminal markers cannot be
used to diagnose osteoporosis they can
be used to assess rates of bone turnover
fracture risk and changes with her all
therapy but the diagnosis of
osteoporosis as you know is made on the
basis of either a low trauma fracture in
the absence of even bone density or a
whu-oh criteria T score by bone density
of minus 2.5 or lower either one of
those are valid diagnostic criteria I
think it's also important for me to
point decide that the T score can be
perfectly normal and you can make the
diagnosis of osteoporosis and people who
have had certain types of low trauma
fractures and that's an important point
to make the rapid change this is a slide
from the UK from Richard Estella's group
that shows on the left hand side the
change in bone density and on the right
hand side the change in the marker with
treatment so you see the the the left
hand the right hand side with treatment
this was a bisphosphonate s' the
dropping marker occurs beyond what's
called the LSC
or the least significant change within
three months whereas it took two years
to see the rise in bone density with
this anti resorbed evasion and so again
this is how they can be complementary
because you can get an earlier feedback
at a quicker shorter period of time with
a marker with the therapy this is
another slide from early Lieberman from
Israel from the eliminate data the left
hand slide shows the percent change in
the urinary NTX which was the marker
widely used earlier in earlier days and
the marker dropping significantly by the
bye week for after starting a litter
nade whereas it took at least 18 months
in the groups of people to see the
increase in bone density so again an
example how markers can be used and they
change more rapidly this is a slide for
again for you from the UCSF group from
Dennis Dennis black who's done
major amount of work in this area the
this is the change in the CTX in the red
the bone resorption marker and the green
the bone formation marker with a litter
Nate now you're going to ask well why
are you using a bone formation marker to
monitor a change with an answer resort
of agent when do you have the bone
resorption marker the principal of this
slide is this is the is to make you
realize that for most of the drugs that
we have in most bone biology the
osteoblasts and the osteoclast cells are
coupled that is whatever you do to one
cell line there'll be a directional
change in the other cell line so when
you decrease osteoblasts and osteoclasts
activity with eliminate the CTX will
drop rapidly and then ultimately the
osteoblasts activity will go down and
that's demonstrated here by the drop in
the osteoblasts marker the P one and P
so actually you can use a P one and P as
a bone resorption marker it takes a
little longer to get the resorption
marker the formation marker down with
anti resorbed of agents but this is the
principle of the biology of the coupling
of both bone cell lines in the same vein
this slide shows the rise in the
osteoblasts marker the P 1 and P when
using an anabolic agent that stimulates
the osteoblasts but also shows the rise
in a slower rate in the bone resorption
marker the NTX with teriparatide so here
you get a simulation of the osteoblasts
and so in the green the p 1 and p goes
up faster and higher but then in a
delayed manner the ntx will go up as
well and this is the principle of
coupling and this is a nice
demonstration from the paper and the
archives of internal medicine and this
head-to-head trial by my good friend and
colleague mike McClung
another slide by david Dempster our good
Scottish friend and histah morphometry
at Columbia University up at the West
Haverstraw hospital in Helen Hayes New
York
this shows Buganda comparing
teriparatide on the left and anabolic
agent with zoledronic acid on the right
and anti resort of agent and in the
green the P one and P in the pink the
CTX and again with the anabolic agent
the faster and earlier eyes with an
anabolic marker people on the P but then
later on a rise in the CTX on the right
hand side with an anti resort of agent
the faster drop in the in the resorption
marker the CT extra seat till a peptide
and the red followed by the drop in the
bone formation marker the P 1 and P
underpinning again this the known
biology of a coupling of bone cell lines
bone markers can be used as a predictor
of increased fracture risk population
studies elevated markers increase
fracture risk in untreated patients at
least in groups of people and it's a
risk factor not captured in Frank's this
comes from probably the pivotal study of
that this is a population study from
France from pet Cornero published in the
jvm are showing this is the epidote
french population study for each two
standard deviations of CTX above the T
score the odds ratio for fracture risk
doubles so here gone from left to right
the increased fracture risk based on low
bone density of the hip by itself in the
middle on the high C T X by itself the
seat X is in the white another bone
resorption marker was DP D or D arcy
paired Emmaline which is not used much
any longer but then you combine the two
the low bone density and the high marker
it gives you a better prediction than
either one alone and this was probably
the pivotal study that point out this
utilization at least some groups of
patients of how high bone turnover can
be used to predict the increased risk of
fracture at the same bone density this
is a summary of a number of other
population studies the one that I just
went through initially is the epidote
study there's studies from Rotterdam the
Oakleigh study there German study
showing that for a marker that's
elevated but and these were in the upper
quartile of the normal reference range
for example that it increased the odds
ratio of different types of fracture
hips fracture non spine fractures spine
fractures above that it assessed by bone
density alone this is a study on the
formation markers this one here was the
bone a plan phosphatase or the serum
osteocalcin again a high marker
predicting an increased risk of fracture
at equivalent BMDs domino density this
is a long longitudinal study that was
published by Avaya Saka from Malmo
Sweden in the JB amar in 2010 that a
high C T X in the highest turtle nine
years later predicted an increase hazard
ratio of all clinical fractures and that
was adjusted even for the baseline bone
mineral density so it looked like a high
marker over a long period of time
predicted an increased risk of fracture
and there's a lot of theories behind
this a good it could be because higher
bone turnover you've got more resorption
cavities they make it deeper the the
areas that david Dempster is described
well on electron micrographs of what are
called stress risers they're more
they're more of them they become weaker
and the bow made fracture at the
equivalent BMD again in groups of
patients reduction with anti resorbed of
agents predict a decrease risk of
fracture this is a meta-analysis from
mark Hochberg at the University of
Maryland in the Rheumatology division
showing the drop in the bone resorption
marker over time in a number of studies
with an to resort of agents most of
these were bisphosphonate studies
different bisphosphonate study would
eliminate worse in turn eight the point
of the slide that there seemed to be a
it's not a true linear relationship but
some linear relationship between the
magnitude of drop in the NT X in this
particular study bone resorption marker
and the magnitude of reduction in
fracture risk this is another slide that
came from the illiterate data this was
from Richard Estelle's publication the
jbm are in 2003 looking at urinary C
checks with reset innate and showing
that there was a relationship between
the magnitude of reduction in the CTX
and the magnitude of fracture adduction
in incident vertebral fractures this
came from the litter innate data the
last one was from the return a data this
came from the fraction I mentioned trial
so again from from Doug Bower using
again the bone formation marker as a
resorption marker because again that the
coupling between bone cell lines and
this slide shows the relationship
between the drop in the bone apple and
phosphatase and the reduction over four
years in incident vertebral fractures
this is a more recent slide looking from
jocks group in JB and mark 2012 and this
shows in the zoledronic acid studies the
relationship between this is a log scale
between and the placebo is in the dotted
line the I mean so I'm sorry that the
placebo is the solid line and zoledronic
acid is in the dotted line the drop and
the P 1 and P again using the P 1 and P
as a resorption marker to the magnitude
and fracture risk reduction in the
zoledronic acid trial to show that
that's compared to placebo the greater
reduction in bone resorption led to a
greater reduction in fracture incident
rates the in the freedom trial the data
with C T X and P 1 and P there wasn't
enough data captured on the markers to
show the relationship between marker
changes with the nos ABAB to the change
in fracture risk we certainly have a
very linear relationship in the Dadaab
data between the increase in total hit
BMD and the any exceptional fracture
adduction that was seen at the hip with
de NOSSA Bob but no bone turnover marker
data
what about anabolic data this is a slide
looking at the changes that comparing
these two anabolic markers if you want
to look at it that way the P 1 and P and
the bone a slur phosphatase and this
just shows that with 20 micrograms a day
a sub-q of teriparatide the p 1 and p
shows greater increases and our way even
though it slice shown on this slide
cerimon stick calcine tracks the P 1 and
P changes closely as well much better
than the bone apple and phosphatase as
an anabolic marker
this slide here shows the change of the
p1 CP which is another portion of the
the peptide to come down to the
osteoblasts on the right hand side in a
similar result is the p1 NP and this
shows the increase in P 1 and P from
baseline to three months later highly
relate it to the increase in the spine
BMD at month 18 so here a three month
increase in P 1 and P highly correlated
with the improvement in bone density
later on down the road now this is
interesting slide because this is a
historic Pharma tree a slide looking at
different parameters of bone from bone
biopsies look at bone volume looking at
the width of the trabecular area and
this is looking at bone Athol and
phosphatase the point of this slide is
the show that again an increase in a
formation marker was highly correlated
with improvements in certain micro
structural changes of bone by bone
biopsy this is from Harald objects group
paper published the JCM in 2005 this is
a paper that we recently published John
Craig II clinical scientist with Lilly
was the first author on this paper this
is the pooled data from the various
teriparatide clinical trials looking at
the change in the placebo group - the
change in the P 1 and P from baseline -
one month after started teriparatide if
you pull this article that was published
- Nasia Prosis international just this
past year it will show you that an
increase in p 1 and p from baseline of
more than 10 microgram per liter
was highly correlated with increases in
bone density was highly correlated with
with increases in bone micro structural
impaired bone biopsies so that the
cutoff point for what might be a
pharmacological response to terror
parricide is an increase in P 1 and P of
10 microgram per liter there's no there
wasn't enough fracture data in these
pooled trials to say what the increase
in P 1 and P from baseline would
translate into decreases in fracture
incidence but certainly there was enough
data to look at it with a change in bone
density or bone micro structural
improvement on pair of bone biopsies
this is a nice paper from sarah glover
working with richard Estelle's lab in
the UK
published in bone in 2009 look at it at
different markers the bone alkaline
phosphatase the osteocalcin the P 1 and
P the P 1 and CP with teriparatide and
then of course on the right hand side
the bone resorption markers and what
this slide shows fundamentally is that
the increase in the P 1 and P and the
osteocalcin are very similar as
osteoblast activity marker responses the
teriparatide better than the bone a
planned phosphatase or p1 it or p1 CP
and that's the point of that slide by
Sarah now this is a little harder to
read and I apologize but this also comes
from Richard Estelle's group looking at
the changes in serum osteocalcin
this is another osteoblast activity
marker in the glucocorticoid data from
the top panel the pre menopausal woman
in the middle panel postmenopausal woman
and the bottle panel the men and showing
that even a month one again the as
compared to a litter Nate the
osteocalcin goes up you would expect to
go down with the live grenade and these
changes are seen
even a month one in this particular
slide you can see this even in the
patients on steroids with osteocalcin as
an icy blast murder this looks again at
this whole biology this is from John's
slide the show again to the increase in
the bone formation marker with
teriparatide even at month one after
starting no change at month one in the
bone resorption marker but because of
the coupling between bone cell lines
that when you increase bone information
or osteoblasts activity you will
increase IC class activity and then
ultimately you'll see the rise in the
ntx certainly the preferred marker for
monitoring teriparatide will be P one
and P or osteocalcin but this just shows
the biology again these coupling of cell
lines now what about drug holidays drug
holidays become a hot topic particularly
in the bisphosphonates field and this
was an FDA hearing September 9 2011 that
was ultimately followed by two
editorials in the New England Journal of
Medicine one from the FDA itself from
Whitaker and colleagues and then another
accompanying editorial by Dennis black
and Doug Bower and colleagues because
the FDA was it was interested in
limitation of use for two reasons one
was the fact that bisphosphate
pharmacology is very unusual the only
drug in clinical medicine that's not
metabolized they get retained in bone
and they get recycled come off bone
surfaces go back to another bone
remodeling site and continue to work and
they have this recycling phenomena that
can last some time for a long time and
have a persistence of effect after
discontinuation another concern another
not a conservative
reason for continuing concern on holiday
was the lack of
of efficacy data beyond five years which
is really something that may not be
achievable anyway because you can't
continue placebo groups and you're
always completely on three to five years
for ethical reasons and you're always
comparing incident rates beyond that it
with with the old recibo groups the
third reason was the appearance of these
atypical subtrochanteric femur fractures
these rare fractures that are dramatic
though which are not seen hardly it at
anybody before five years of you so what
do we do and how do we tell patients and
how do we counsel patients when we stop
you their therapy and this is a
challenge because there's not a lot of
data and so a lot of this will be
opinion and some some practical clinical
guidance and what we think about well
what about markers well this comes from
the Flex trial the Fosamax long-term
extension looking at the serum CTX on
the left-hand side of the horizontal
line is the fit trial the fracture
intervention trial the pivotal trials
that led to eliminates approval this is
the this is the debate on left hand side
is between the placebo and the treated
groups follow-up for five years the Flex
data or the so called Fosamax long term
extension it was the women that agreed
to go on to five more years and it was
the treated group that agreed that were
reran demised into a either continuing
treatment that's shown in the yellow or
coming off so fundamentally the ones
that came off had been on for five years
and now we're taking off the serum CTX
begins the rise you can see that it
actually became significantly different
than those that stayed on at year three
not at year one and year two so this is
a hint a suggestion that maybe the
biological effects of bisphosphonates is
waning after people have been on for
five years by year three
the real question is what happens to
fractures because even though bone
turnover may go up it doesn't
necessarily translate into impairment
and bone strength and we do have some
fracture data in the Flex trial and the
people that were taken off there were no
differences he would go from right to
left from the hip fractures between
those who stayed on that those who came
off in non vertebral fractures or in
morphometric x-ray defined vertebral
fractures there was however a 55 percent
greater increase in clinical painful
vertebral fractures in those that came
off than those in the yellow that stayed
on for ten years this data would suggest
that there is there could be a
relationship between the rise in the
marker and the increase in the fracture
risk this is not proven this is not
validated you the sickle power of this
was not done to look at these
relationships in that matter this is an
association between the rise in the
marker and the increased risk of
fracture
similarly in the horizon trials the
zoledronic acid trials the patients that
got in the core study in the black 3
years of zoledronic acid then a group
were either given three more doses so
they're called a z6 the one in the
orange they got six doses of annual five
milligrams electronic acid and a group
that had been on for three years were
taken off the so-called Z 3 P 3 this is
the change in the P one and P the P 1
and P again as a resorption marker
because of the fact that when you
increase bone when bone resorption
begins to go up you'll see a rise in the
P 1 to P as well you'll see that the P 1
and P went up and it was increased by
the second maybe 18 months of stopping
and and stayed at that level and those
differences
were significant from the ones that
stayed on here is the change in the
fractures in the extension study there
was only an increase in the morphometric
vertebral fractures by about 30 or 40
percent as compared to those that stayed
on again data suggesting that there may
be an association between the rise in
the marker and the changes in bone
strength it's not powered for this
conclusion but there is this
relationship this has come from a number
of papers that we published over the
last number of years most patients don't
stay on therapy as you know the
compliance data particularly the oral
bisphosphonates is poor but to extend
that we try to keep people on and keep
people on for at least three to five
years you know and now we have this
direction of strong suggestion from the
community that we ought to give people a
holiday particularly if they're lower
risk and maybe not keep people holiday
if they're high risk we'll switch them
to another drug and in in the United
States we have a problem with our legal
issues with regard to what happens if a
patient fractures because you kept them
on or if they fracture you could took
them off so these are important
considerations we don't know how long
holidays are going to last even though
we have some of this data because the
pharmacology bisphosphonates differ and
they may come off bone differently and
you know you can never know from one
patient to the next what there's total
skeletal load is of bisphosphonates
which may be dependent upon their
compliance or how much they absorbed or
how much of a remodeling space they had
when they started taking the
bisphosphonates so in that regard we
have we have to do something even though
we don't have a lot of data by any means
to monitor people to provide feedback to
them that where do you think this is
still working or not working and what to
do so at the current time in the
clinical community you'll see a lot of
development of guidelines suggesting
that if you do stop bisphosphonates and
lower risk patients that we should
monitor bone mineral density
periodically and bone turnover markers
there are the only clinical tools that
we have them to monitor it's important
to point out that changes in bone
density or bone turnover markers in
order to be significant should be beyond
the so-called LSC or the leases that can
change of that marker and that is
dependent on the precision air of the
labs as well as the bone densitometry
facility what doc should do in these
holidays discuss why you're taking
patients off you should explain the
differences in pharmacology because we
may not want to stop people necessarily
on drugs that don't have the unique
pharmacology at this phosphonates you
stop statins the LDL goes up you stop
high blood pressure medications the
blood pressure goes up you fill you this
fascinating pharmacology allows this
consideration explain that if their risk
is low that it's just a low because of
this recycling if they're higher risk
and this comes from that some of the
directions provided by both the FDA in
Whitaker's editorial and dennis black
and his editorial if they have high
risks that would be defined as people
who have had prior fractures or people
who had femoral neck t scores of minus
2.5 or lower or older people who are
have a higher risk of falling you should
either stop them and put them on a
different pharmacology
pharmacological agent or if you're going
to stop them you have to watch them
carefully you should advise of symptoms
that could proceed in a typical fracture
even if you stopped it as foster think
because the risk goes down but it
doesn't completely go away and we
monitor Heights
we monitor bone density we monitor bone
turnover it's all we have in our current
clinical black-bag
what about the nos mob these are the
last couple of slides the more have a QA
the nicer mob is metabolised it's
monoclonal antibody to rank ligand it's
a wonderful medicine it's got great data
to reduce fracture risk of all fracture
sites given 60 milligrams sub-q every
six months this is the paper that I was
privileged to be the first author on the
phase 2 data when you stop it and you
see the CTX here on the left-hand side
and the purple you see the sheet text
not only going back to baseline but it
overshoots baseline within a few months
the effect goes away the the effect goes
away rapidly but we don't know what
happens to fracture if there's no
fracture data yet but this is a drug
that we probably have to continue at
least for a long time in order to to
maintain the biological effect that's an
opinion so what is the relationship
between the rise in bone turnover marker
and the subsequent risk for fracture
with discontinuation of Dena sebab we
have no data but I what a put in
perspective the fact that the bone
turnover being high as a reflection of
an increased fracture as' and untreated
people might be entirely different than
changes in bone tumor markers in treated
people because there's a lot more to
bone strain than bone density or bone
turnover so biochemical markers of bone
turnover have complementary roles to
bone mineral density in the management
of postmenopausal osteoporosis can be
used for fracture as prediction and
monitoring spawns two pharmacological
therapy for osteoporosis show changes
with therapy sooner than changed a bone
mineral density provide earlier feedback
and both resorption as well as formation
markers are available and have specific
value in specific clinical scenarios and
with that I think I will finish and
thank you very much for your attention
for being here I hope this was
beneficial to you
and I'm very happy to take any question
that you may have
don't be shy
I want to make sure that wasn't somebody
coughing okay so here is a question what
is relationship of between bone tumor
markers and fracture nonunions that's a
great question I I don't know the answer
to that you would you you I don't know
if there's any data on that a if it is
I'm not aware of it I would my opinion
would be that if it's very high bone
turnover it could impair fracture
healing although I don't know that I
would also think that very low bone
turnover and like for example in Aden I
mean bone disease might impair fracture
healing I would bet you that data
there's some data out there but I don't
know that answer another question is
what are your thoughts on the use of
strontium citrate for osteoporosis well
you know strontium Ranelagh that
particular salt of strontium is approved
in Europe under the brand name proto
loose for the treatment of
postmenopausal osteoporosis and and it's
got something impressive particularly
hip fracture data in a very elderly
population there's a certain dose of
strontium that's required to get this
osteoblasts effect if it's truly an
Aussie blast effect it may not be the
Kay
and the problem is is that the
over-the-counter preparations that we
have here available since strontium
Ranelagh is unavailable in the United
States they never did any clinical
trials in the United States to get an
FDA approval and I don't think is
available in Canada is it's far lower
than the proven dose and the clinical
trial data so if it has a biological
effect it's not been studied at these
lower doses and I look at it the current
time is probably being more homeopathic
than truly with evidence-based data
here's another question this is a great
one I guess they're all great questions
thank you what is your recommendation
for monitoring a patient with a clue
Concordia induce osteoporosis on a drug
holiday well it's a real it could be a
bigger problem because you know
glucocorticoid suppress bone remodeling
particularly when they're chronic and so
you expect to see low markers and
certainly on bone biopsies reseed low
bone turnover on dynamic parameters of
history morphometry but they should come
up and they do come up and while we you
know the the effect of people corticoids
on inhibiting remodeling inhibiting
osteoblasts activity for example should
wane if they're completely stopped and
this may be a problem because they're
often tapered down and that should wane
within a few months and so i don't think
there's a lot of data on holidays but I
think that monitoring seek txp wanted P
osteocalcin could be available although
the changes may be slower but it may
take them being completely off google
corticoids rather than simply
point five milligrams of prednisone a
day for example I would use them I would
look at them I think that changes over
time they give you a trend over time or
much more valuable than a single
measurement that's for sure and I think
that I would use them and watch them in
that regard the problem and that's the
people that are completely off the
problem is that people that are even on
two-and-a-half and well granted
prednisone a day and this is comes from
the general practice research database
the bond-style database that even two
and a half milligrams a day if it's
given over a long period of time will
cause fractures as compared to no
steroids so I guess the question would
be more probable in terms of changes
that you would expect and management in
people completely off that would be my
opinion on that we still have 39 people
on the line you got to have a question
this comes the fun part for me here's a
question recommend a clinical approach
in postmenopausal women with
osteoporosis with no previous fracture
low bone density I'm assuming that the
osteoporosis is being defined by the
whu-oh criteria of - 2.5 or lower low
bone density predicts an increased risk
of fracture but it's heavily age
dependent so for every decade over the
age of 50 the fracture is doubles at any
skeletal site at the same bone density
and that's because older bone has
changes in bone quality that we can't
measure yet in clinical practice we may
be getting a handle on this with the use
of trabecular bone score but that
remains to be widely utilized so the 50
year old at minus 2.5 has a much lower
fracture risk than the
eighty-year-old at minus 2.5 and that's
probably one of the most important
considerations is age this is where I
think the whu-oh fracks helps us the
fracture risk assessment modeling it was
again the 10-year project underwritten
by the WH o there's an app fort now on
your on your iPhone or iPad and you can
put in the nine validated risk factors
that were there and found to be
validated over a ten year period to
predict the ten year risk of either a
major fracture or by itself hip fracture
and untreated people fracks helps to
some degree because it adds these other
risk factors and adds age it adds
whether you're on prednisone
it adds family history it adds a prior
fracture all to the question you have is
it without a prior factor now the
question comes down to what is the frac
score that would trick trip your finger
to treat well the recommendations out
from the study remember this is a
healthy economic study is a major
fracture as' of 20% or higher or hip
fracture risk of three percent or higher
I use that to some degree but but I
modified clinically if I have a
Parkinson's patient in front of me who's
gonna fall more I may not use that
threshold it may be even a lower
threshold on the other hand if I have
somebody who is a Pilates instructor and
could probably be the Olympics on the
balance beam they're gonna fall less I
might not use that threshold because one
of the flaws of fracks say that ten
times real quick one of the flaws of
fracks and is the fact that he we didn't
capture thought they didn't capture fall
data and most fractures except for
vertebral fractures occur after Falls so
I modify this in clinical practice so if
a person who's nineteen percent and two
point nine percent has a CT X that's
fifteen
with the epilator normal 650 they have
high bone turnover
I might start him earlier that was the
my that was a reason I put that in a
slide about it might tip my scale so I
think that and and of course you know
the nof national I suppose foundation
and other have suggests treating people
at minus 2.5 that are postmenopausal I
modified that according to age I think
that the 50 year old who's out here in
our state that there's a lot of active
people who have better muscle tone will
probably fall less or healthier I may
wait a while if their hi-fi markers I
may not I hope that answers some of your
thoughts on that thank you for the
question it's a good question do you
know if there are any updates to the use
of bone markers in renal osteodystrophy
yes I do in fact and this is not to push
my own horn but in last month's American
Journal of kidney disease I wrote an
invited review article on the bone
diseases in CKD and how to discriminate
them from osteoporosis so it's the
american journal of kidney disease I
know it was online in January I think
it's a hard copy but and I summarized
some of that data in there the best data
comes from a group in London that looked
at 1200 about 1200 bone biopsy data
collected over a period of time and
correlated the degree of bone turnover
with the appellant's the tissue
nonspecific alkaline phosphatase and and
PTH those that had peat th's below a
hundred pukka gram per milliliter and a
alkaline phosphatase and the lower
quartile had a very high probability of
having a dynamic bone disease
if they had a PTH below 150 and a and
then alkaline phosphatase in lower
quartile the sensitivity for a dynamic
bone disease I think was about 85% if
they have a high bone alkaline
phosphatase they probably don't have a
dynamic bone disease they might not have
hyperthyroidism may have our stimulation
they could have Paget's a good but it
was the very low values that had a
higher positive predictive value for a
divided bone disease which is probably
the bone disease that we want to exclude
a lot of in people who may be thinking
about using an to resort of agents for
fractures because even though there's no
data it doesn't make sense to me at
least of this particular point in our in
the science to reduce bone remodeling
when you had very little to no bone
remodeling to begin with but I think if
you looked at that
the the original work was done by
Garrett and but I review all that in the
American Journal kidney disease review
as well that might be a little easier to
get all the the Garrett's paper was I'm
just I'm blocking right now I think the
clinical Journal of the American Society
of Nephrology I think it was a sage c CJ
ASN that's a great question and it's an
important question
well I hear from dime but there's no
more questions available if you're still
listening to me I appreciate your
attention and I hope this was useful
again thank you very very much